[Música]
una de las técnicas de ideación del
proceso de innovación que ha aprendido
se llama los impulsores de mejorar es
una técnica bastante sencilla tú tomas
una idea que ya existe le aplicas un
impulsor que básicamente es una
tarjetita con una instrucción y generas
una nueva idea uno de estos impulsores
tiene que ver con la sustracción qué
quiere decir esto le quito un elemento o
un componente a una idea que ya existe
cuando tengo que explicarle esto a
equipos de funcionarios públicos para
que podamos generar ideas e innovadora
tengo un ejemplo clásico que pasa si
sacamos al profesor del aula
y esto ya no es un ejercicio de
prospectiva esto ya no es un ejercicio
que lo realicemos solamente para
fomentar la creatividad para generar
innovaciones hoy día esto es una
realidad
les presento a mi profesor de francés
acá está
con la inteligencia artificial hoy en
día mi profesor de frase no solamente me
enseña vocabulario estructura gramatical
sino que la aplicación puede corregir
como yo estoy escribiendo como yo estoy
pronunciando y lo mejor de todo es que
puedo tomar la clase cuando quiero a la
hora que quiero y donde quiera
por tanto hoy día las salas las aulas se
ven así
en este sentido además existe mucho
contenido ya en línea efectivamente la
mayor parte del contenido hoy ya está en
algún formato abierto existen más de 81
millones de estudiantes en cursos en
línea tenemos más de 800 universidades a
nivel mundial que tienen al menos un
curso en formato muro y esto equivale a
9.4 millones de cursos disponibles se
han preguntado a ustedes si su curso
está en alguna de estas plataformas
donde están las mejores universidades y
los mejores docentes
entonces cuál es el valor agregado que
estamos entregando en la experiencia
universitaria si es que ya el contenido
lo tenemos disponible y aquí es donde yo
les quiero contar una anécdota personal
a los 17 decidí estudiar sociología
porque quería cambiar el mundo
probablemente se ríen yo lo sé
probablemente se ríen porque están
pensando exactamente lo mismo que me
usaron mis padres quiero una idealista
y aún así seguí adelante y decidí
estudiar sociología y llegué a mis
primeros años y tuve cursos de las más
variadas disciplinas estudia economía
estudia estadística teoría social
psicología estudia de todo y lo peor que
me podían preguntar mientras que yo
estaba en la universidad era que hace un
sociólogo
qué hace un sociólogo y todo el mundo
que está estudiando sociología y que es
un sociólogo y la respuesta que yo en
ese minuto podía dar era la respuesta
que me enseñó mi profesor de teoría
social analizamos el orden social
qué significa eso
lo podía decir salía del paso con esa
respuesta pero no tenía idea que
significaba analizar el orden social y
peor aún quién me va a pagar por
analizar el orden social cuando salga de
esta carrera
y esto se pone mucho más grave porque
finalmente todos los trabajos que yo
hice mientras que estuve en la
universidad eran temáticas de
investigación que probablemente
solamente me interesaban a mí y a mi
grupo de trabajo y que no tenían ninguna
relevancia en cinco años de proceso
formativo no estuve ni cerca y lo puedo
decir ahora con razón de causa no no
estuve ni cerca de aproximarme aquí era
lo que hacía un sociólogo mucho menos en
el aula me estaba dando una posibilidad
de que yo pudiera transformar el mundo y
esa era mi motivación inicial de entrar
a esta carrera
y lo que les quiero dejar planteado es
que esto está gravísimo porque por un
tema de alcance de números yo alcanzo a
autodenominarse como generación
millennial pero nuestros estudiantes hoy
en día tienen el tema del propósito y el
sentido mucho más ha presentado que mi
generación y el problema es que la
manera en que estamos haciendo las
clases no ha cambiado tanto desde que yo
salí de la universidad
es tanto así que nuestros estudiantes
quieren cambiar el mundo quieren dejar
un espacio mejor que no solamente pasa
en los ambientes universitarios ya
vienen desde el colegio con esta
motivación no sé si han escuchado de
creta tamberg esta activista climática
de 16 años y está pero transformando el
mundo 16 años imagínense cuando llegue a
la universidad las universidades ya sus
aulas están repletas de estudiantes que
quieren transformar el mundo la pregunta
es qué es lo que estamos haciendo como
incorporamos entonces este ímpetu esta
motivación este propósito que tienen los
estudiantes como parte de la experiencia
de aprendizaje
como efectivamente les explicamos a
nuestros estudiantes que van a ser
capaces luego con todos los
conocimientos que están adquiriendo y
ahí es donde yo les quiero dejar una
invitación que es real de que las
universidades han avanzado harto esto
porque es un problema
los estudiantes se desmotivan y de ser
cierto baja los indicadores de retención
estudiantes y por tanto una de las
estrategias que han utilizado es empezar
a mover cursos disciplinares a los
primeros años y eso ha sido un esfuerzo
importante para que efectivamente los
estudiantes puedan entender que
bendiciones hacen en sus carreras pero
no es suficiente para que ellos
realmente puedan canalizar esta energía
transformadora con la que llegan a
nuestras aulas y esa es la invitación
que yo les quiero dejar yo quiero que
reflexionen de qué manera podemos
acercar estos desafíos que tenemos en el
entorno a nuestras aulas y eso desde mi
experiencia se puede hacer a través de
una metodología que se llama aprendizaje
y servicio y que es aprendizaje el
servicio no es otra cosa que tomar esos
contenidos curriculares
ustedes ya tienen en sus cátedras y
vincularlos con alguna necesidad del
entorno ya sea un emprendedor si es que
estás en el área de los negocios puede
ser un servicio público puede ser el
tercer sector en general lo que queremos
hacer es mejorar las experiencias de los
estudiantes a medida que ellos pueden
efectivamente utilizar esa motivación de
transformación y de paso estamos
apoyando a alguien que quizás va a
recibir un producto o un servicio que de
otra forma no podría acceder por tanto
estamos entregando un bien a la
comunidad
nos sobran problemas sociales y públicos
en este país nos sobran problemas
entonces la consigna es dejemos de hacer
trabajos sin sentido
dejemos de pedirle a los estudiantes que
inventen planes de negocios hipotéticos
para empresas que no existen cuando
tenemos emprendedores que no tienen
planes de negocios y se van a beneficiar
de eso el poder explicarle al otro el
contenido que yo estoy aprendiendo el
poder asesorar el poder aplicar en
concreto va a mejorar mi experiencia de
aprendizaje pero de ahí más me va a
entregar un sentido de propósito que me
va a mantener motivado y que
efectivamente mejora los desempeños de
nuestros estudiantes porque porque están
aprendiendo el contexto real y en ese
sentido la evidencia que van a tener a
través de una experiencia de aprendizaje
y servicio no es replicable dentro de un
aula de clase estamos cambiando la
manera en que vemos a nuestros
estudiantes que aunque no hayan
terminado su proceso formal de educación
son capaces de entregar aportes
espectaculares y por otro lado estamos
transformando y revitalizando el rol de
ustedes el rol de los docentes porque
porque ya no sirve que seamos meros
transmisores de conocimiento el
conocimiento ya está ahí en la nube lo
que sí aporta valor es que ustedes
puedan ven torear a esos estudiantes en
las cosas que nos salen en los libros en
las cosas que nos salen en el curso
online que tiene que ver con lo
relacional con manejar la incertidumbre
con qué hago si es que la persona que
estoy asesorando no está reconociendo o
no quiere tomar el consejo que yo doy
esos son los desafíos profesionales que
realmente nosotros enfrentamos en el día
a día pero que nos estamos preparando a
nuestros estudiantes para que lo puedan
hacer una vez que egresen de nuestras
aulas y este cambio de como nosotros
tomamos esta motivación con la que
vienen nuestros estudiantes no solamente
es un desafío a nivel universidad esto
está cambiando el mercado laboral las
empresas hoy día están preocupadísimas
en cómo pueden retener
las generaciones porque porque estas
generaciones necesitan un propósito
transformador no les basta solamente
trabajar para ganar dinero necesitan
saber que están haciendo algo con
sentido y esto por ejemplo ha generado
toda esta ola de empresas de donde ya no
solamente es importante ganar los
recursos sino preocuparse por el
equilibrio social y medioambiental que
estamos haciendo nosotros en las
universidades para aprovechar ese ímpetu
que tienen estos estudiantes
esa es hoy obviamente
lo que yo quería ahora cómo evidenciar
es que cuando leí efectivamente el
instructivo que nos mandaban para
preparar esta charla yo ya sé que estoy
en algo falle en que una de las
recomendaciones que me dieron es que yo
tenía que tratar de traerles una idea
nueva y en eso falle rotundamente porque
esta idea no es nueva esta idea ya viene
de aristóteles que decía que la
inteligencia no sólo consiste en el
conocimiento sino que en la destreza de
poder aplicar esos conocimientos en la
práctica por tanto ayudemos
efectivamente a que los estudiantes
puedan tener esa destreza en la realidad
y una última invitación para que ustedes
ojalá se queden con la reflexión vean
sus cátedras y efectivamente analicen de
qué manera lo pueden hacer porque en la
experiencia que he tenido asesorando
cursos y asesorando profesores no hay
cátedra que no se puede innovar no hay
cátedra que no pueda utilizar
aprendizaje activo y no hay cátedra que
no tenga una vinculación efectiva con
las necesidades reales de la sociedad
sino no sería conocimiento que hoy día
necesitáramos como humanidad
y aquí la última idea
quizás esto de vincular el currículum
con las necesidades de la sociedad no es
nueva ya lo dije pero lo que sí yo
aprendido en los procesos de
implementación o de innovación es que no
solamente necesitas una nueva idea o
quizás una idea ya existente sino que
esa idea tiene que generar valor para
las personas y se tiene que implementar
y donde estamos cortos es en implementar
en transformar nuestras aulas por tanto
ese era como el mensaje y la
transformación que yo los quiero llamar
a ser parte para que efectivamente
nuestros estudiantes puedan tener una
mejor experiencia de aprendizaje pero a
la vez podamos estar generando el bien
común muchas gracias
[Aplausos]